[Music]
hallo YouTube chess Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to my
forty second episode of chest trap
series in this episode I'm going to show
you a wonderful trap in the four nights
italian from the black perspective the
opening arises after the falling model
evo 'if i Knight to f3 Knight to c6
Bishop to c4 Knight to f6 and here white
has various options such as Knight to g5
leads to the fried liver and the lolly
attack d3 leads to the more positional
modern italian game where d4 leads to
max lang and the morphe attack territory
which i had covered in detail in my
dotage Astrix sixth and the seventh
episode however there is a fourth option
namely Knight to c3 so as you can see
there are four Knights developed on the
table and because what has put the
bishop on c4 this is known as four
Knights Italian game
which is in fact very common at the club
level and below 2,000 practice
now against this the most popular choice
is Bishop to c5 but there is a better
move available in this position namely
Knight captures a foe
so not only destroying the white center
but the big tactical point is when white
capture this piece we are going to get
our piece back with this thematic break
defy
okay white doesn't want to give up the
bishop pan so accordingly there are two
popular choices
well Bishop to b5 leads to over trappy
line but before we look at it there is a
brief note about Bishop to d3 yes I
think this is very passive choice by
white and after the following
continuation D captures ephone Bishop
captures e4
White has a threat of Bishop capture c6
and Knight captures ePHI which black
easily parry with Bishop to d6 and as
you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows once black castles and later on
managed to play a fight with this
wonderful Center and King side activity
it is only black who is having all the
fun in this line
so this is how you should respond
against the move Bishop to d3
however the more common approach here is
white continue with Bishop to b5 which
has a very nasty idea as the Black
Knight is spin when black recaptured the
piece white deliver this nasty Trump
Knight captures Aoife which at first
sight looks so cool as there is a double
attack on c6 and not so surprising if we
check this position in online database
there are more than 700 games played
from this position
well believe it or not but why has
straightaway fallen into black strappy
territory and the trappy business start
with this very cute move Queen to g5 so
black queen is attacking multiple
locations such as these two pieces as
well as on g2 and that means white
response is force there are three
replies what has tried which all leads
to the miserable position so let's see
each bite on the first move I want to
consider ace Bishop captures c6 which
destroy the black queen side however now
the problem comes to the surface yes
white cannot say you both the spot and
the most natural move in the world
Knight capture c6 completely fails due
to the following forcing sequence Queen
captures g2 attacking the rook rook to
have fun and now this deciding blow so
suddenly White Queen is strapped and the
only way to rescue the Queen is to play
f3 but after Bishop captures f3 rook
captures f3 and the move he captures f3
no matter however my place in the next
to moose the spawn ruler will make white
resigned the cave
you
the second move I want to consider is
nike after c6 and against this we have
this simple move Queen captures b5
attacking the knight Knight to d4
attacking the Queen and now Queen goes
to his original place Queen to g5
so g2 is a soft spot in all of this line
and funny enough white can't play the
move g3 the simple reason is after
Bishop twitch three his king will be
stuck in the center and not only that in
the next move black is going to castle
on the Quinn side which put hell or
depression on this night I won a very
quick blitz game where my 1800 rated
opponent continued with Quinn to e2
attacking on e4
I simply responded with castle on the
Queen side attacking the knight and if
white played the mu c3 then Bishop to c5
is a very strong reply so my opponent
grabbed the pawn with Queen captures fo
which turn out as a big time disaster as
after the simple response Bishop to c5
my opponent found to his horror that
there is a double attack on Knight and
rook - even is coming which altogether
create a complete chaos for the white
camp and he has to resign in just mere
fifty moves
well apart from g3 there is no easy
route to safeguard the pawn for example
if a white has to play King to have fun
then his King will be severely misplaced
and the most obvious move chaos alone
the King side doesn't work here and I
think he already figure it out right he
up the star mu Bishop to h3 g3 is the
only response but after Bishop takes
have fun quintics have fun just within
the 12th more of the game black obtained
the exchange with a huge advantageous
position for the black cap
you
last but not least what happens if you
oppor and continue with d4 which has a
clear merit of attacking the Queen and
our response is very obvious yup capture
on g2 and after rook to a phone here
comes the second star move a six which
forces white to take either of the two
options the first option Bishop to e4 is
a pretty bad one and the simple reason
is we are going to play the move B Phi
so that if now the bishop moves then we
will take this nine and then play Bishop
to h3 which by force
winning the exchange so more or less
white is obliged to capture this night
but after B takes a fall it turns out
that no matter whatever white plays the
next move is going to come Bishop to h3
and napped exchange
for example a sample line can goes like
this Bishop to e3 Bishop to h3 attacking
the rook which has nowhere to go and the
only move Queen to e2 leads to the loss
of exchange Queen captures f1 Queen
captures have fun Bishop captures have
fun and King cats have fun where at the
end of the sequence black is clearly in
the driving seat with an extra exchange
and a pawn
last but not least what happens if white
continue with Bishop capture c6
well this is the easiest one has after
we capture c6 again of a threat remain
as it is and the only way to parry this
threat is to play counter attacking me
Queen to h5 after g6 white is forced to
exchange the Queen with Queen to g5
but we are more than happy as even after
the Queen exchange let's say Queen takes
bishop takes we are going to play this
crafty move Bishop to g7
which at first sight giving up the c6
pawn and indeed after Knight capture c6
we have the equal material on the board
but see yourself has just one move
Bishop to d7 and black is completely
winning
well you are tacking the night if the
knight moves then the d4 pawn drops
you can't play D Phi as B two ponies
hanging and if white wants to save all
of this thread the only mu is Knight to
e5 saving his all material but
unfortunately it completely fails
because of this simple sequence Bishop
to h3 attacking the rook and after rook
to g1 now comes the sting in the tail AB
six and by force black is winning the
piece and in fact the key
you
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this high profile trap in the four
nights Italian game remember at this
Junction played the move Queen to g5 and
no matter however why triggers the
victory is awaiting in the few moves
over the ball well thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment and I will meet
you in my next episode very soon bye and
take care